I remember when that thing was called an
agra and it caused $5,000 what the hell
Jesus you guys are killing me here Matt
20 50 bucks
great sound is what I'm talking about
yeah yeah absolutely
so this this professor and you don't
have to name the school be best not to
but this professor was giving advice to
students and you noticed that that
advice was either already obsolete or
would be obsolete by the time most of
them paid off their student loans no but
come they graduated by the time they
graduated and what they learned from the
school would be obsolete and they would
not be able to pay off the student loan
with what they learned this is very
upsetting when you went back to you went
back to film school because you said you
in prior press you weren't able to book
roles for a while or you had hit a dip
and so you decided to take matters into
your own hands and become a filmmaker
what things did you retain from that
time was it AFI that's yes okay and what
what were myths so what was extremely
helpful that you still remember today
that you still use whether it's just
people skills or giving feedback to an
actor and what what were myths the
American Film Institute was a great
learning place great men who's partly
responsible for me being in this
industry is named Tony Villani and he
was the head of the American film so at
the time and Tony was a no-nonsense
person at that time was a cutting
process you paid your money and you were
not guaranteed to finish the two years
because every quarter in the basement of
the school there was a sheet of paper if
your name was not on it you were
dismissed
and they were preparing you for the
reality of this industry of the
rejection and how no matter how good you
thought you were good to keep kicking
your game up
and so what it gave me is no matter what
anybody else says about my work and I
see it in the theater I know it could be
better and I'm always thinking about man
I have one more day or one more take
with that actor or whatever it is I
could have done it better so they gave
you a realistic understanding of the
industry and prepared you for it pretty
well I think what every school does it
sent you out there with hopes and dreams
it tells you that it's not going to be
easy but they really don't tell you how
hard it's really gonna be because I
think they don't want to discourage you
from because it's like it's a beast
I mean not for black people anybody I
mean it's like why are we doing it you
see wonder sometimes you I mean well you
know I could be tired I could just live
but you know there's something that um I
had dinner at my house this was like a
year ago and like nine people were there
and the discussion was about in your
lifetime out of all the people you've
ever known what percentage of them ended
up doing what they wanted to do with
their lives edge percentage which three
three percent
so when I look at my good fortune all I
continue to go through and I've been
through but I am still doing at my age
what I want to do with my life and I
wake up every day and I want to do more
I do never want to retire no matter what
the pain has been I feel like I'm
blessed because most of my friends that
I grew up with are dead or if they're
not dead they retired from jobs they
hated that they did for 35 years or more
and they retire and they sit on the
porch and go on cruises and stuff which
is okay
they never enjoy one day at work not one
day there's something
why do you think most people choose that
because I think you know most people
know deep down inside what they really
want to do is it just that it's too
difficult okay well why do most people
make that choice I think security
there's some security and having you
know two kids in the house and the car
working at a job that gives you
insurance for your family vacations
retirement guaranteed it there's a
certain security about having that some
people way happiness against security
for 90% people security always wins
until if you have kids because once you
have a child I mean it's your life is
secondary to the needs of what you've
created in this world but there's
another side to it in that if you wake
up every morning and you don't have
security but you love waking up you love
going to work you love the fights no
matter how painful it is you you will ok
Goliath my stones not that big but I see
you're damn I'm an ice I see right here
man I'm not saying today but you see
this little I'm twirling I'm twirling
the stone you know it's taking me longer
than I thought you're going down
you